ces enceintes bluetooth mais en version
luthier comme bill gates et paul allen
le guyancourt toi christophe duquenne et
le vendéen marc lucas ont monté leur
premier prototype chez eux à partir de
2016 aujourd'hui ils ont créé leur
société la voie du luthier avec deux
produits londe et la pyramide
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il fallait des
enceintes amplificateur classique pour
entendre un instrument électronique
aujourd'hui en fait en offre une caisse
de résonance naturel en bois comme une
caisse de guitare ou une pièce de piano
pour entendre le son de l'instrument
électronique
là ce qu'on va voir l'intérieur on a un
petit amplificateur classe dépendant
celui-là qui fait deux fois 30 watts on
prendra déjà un volume qui relativement
important on a les batteries ayant et
ronald récepteur bluetooth
qui va permettre de gérer tout ça
christophe duquenne est passionné de
musique électronique
de son côté marc lucas est artisan
luthier la libration se propage sur
toute cette table d'harmonie qui va
faire vibrer de l'air et l'air va venir
jusqu'à nos oreilles et c'est comme ça
qu'on va entendre le son de l'accord d'
amplifier ou le sont les créateurs qui
va être amplifié cette start up est
composé d'une dizaine de personnes il
collabore avec d'autres sociétés comme à
cannes audio à l'origine de cet
instrument électronique
c'est un instrument il serait très
expressif et continue donc c'est quelque
chose qui est assez novateur aussi quand
on se rend compte que la musique
électroacoustique rappeler les
guitaristes où les biologistes vont trop
aussi un gros intérêt sur ce type
d'instrument on sera par exemple à
francfort à la musique mais ça ne va pas
être dans la partie électronique l'on
avait dans la partie avec les guitares
et les violons elle est donc présenté
son instrument à d'autres types de
musiciens éric l'udc est membre du
groupe deep forest collabore aussi sur
ce projet prochaine étape une vague de
livraison prévue en avril prochain
[Musique]